have you ever been nominated
no
but between you and me i kind of wrote
my name in every category
like even
this category sound oh yeah
so like what burping
yeah
really
yeah
good luck to you man thanks bro
i think you picked the wrong category
bro
these people are geniuses they are the
nominees for achievement in sound
belfast denise yard simon chase james
mather and neve adiri
dune matt grouth mark mangini theo green
doug hemphill and ron bartlett
no time to die
simon hayes oliver tarney james harrison
paul massey and mark taylor the power of
the dog richard flynn robert mckenzie
and tara webb
west side story today maitland gary
rydstrom brian chumney andy nelson and
sean murphy
and the oscar goes to
doom
oh my goodness
thank you
so much academy
thank you
thank you denis villeneuve
to our amazing director who
was like the spice
you sir with the spice flowing through
our brains turning our humble ideas into
your
imaginary world thank you so much thank
you to hans zimmer thank you to joe
walker who treated us as fellow artists
this is for you
thank you
thank you for everyone from legendary
and warner brothers and to all our
family and friends thank you so much for
your love and support and of course
thank you denis messi de fonte
[Applause]